sie ist eine der einflussreichsten
Frauen im Weltfußball Tatjana Handy
fertig auf dem Berner Wiesloch beginnt
ihre unglaubliche Karriere schon als
Mädchen hat sich hier mit den Jungs
gespielt
entlassen wurde mit 56
Verband wechselt sie als sportdirektorin
in die amerikanische Profi-Liga
alle kennen Tatjana sie ist die beste
ich bin sehr glücklich dass sie die Liga
repräsentiert
seit Jahren begleite ich Tatjana Handy
beruflich taff und souverän so kenne ich
sie von Interviews aber was bewegt der
Schritt nach New York persönlich das
will ich herausfinden
Amerika das ist
immer hier landen
also länger
Anfang April ich begleitet hat Jana
Handy an einen Match in New York der
erste Stadion Besuch in der neuen
Funktionen
ich bin die neue Sportdirektor in der
Liga
gelandet in einem neuen Welt
ist
cooler Fußballerin ist natürlich
Mädchen
immer das kleine Schwester
für Mädchen der beliebteste Sport die
besten Spielerinnen Wechsel vom College
direkt in die Profiliga wir erleben
begeisterte
als Millionen Business nirgends steckt
mehr Geld in Frauenfußball kein
Vergleich zu Europa schon gar nicht zu
Schweiz
als sportdirektorin soll Henry vor allem
Strategien sein Ihr Auftrag und ihr Ziel
die national women Soccer League zur
besten und attraktivsten Liga der Welt
machen um dies zu erreichen steht sie im
dauernd und Austausch mit den Clubs und
deren potenten GeldgeberInnen
vier Monate zuvor ich bin mit Tatjana
Hänni in Bern wo sie herkommt
hallo
es ist dezember 2022
Weihnachtsbummel mit der 81-jährigen
Mutter Inge eine gebürtigen Wienerin
noch zwei Wochen bis zum Abflug nach New
York
richtig gut wirklich richtig gut die
beiden lachen und scherzen doch die
Wehmut ist spürbar
wirklich dass das dass sie das Angebot
hat sehr stolz auf sie finden sie
sowieso tolle Tochter
ja die beste der Welt
und machen ja
schon als Kind wusste Tatjana Handy was
sie wollte als aber das Jobangebot aus
Amerika kam zögerte selbst sie die
Eltern zurückzulassen bereitet ihr Mühe
Nikolaus also mir ein das Schmutzli
geht's in der Schweiz auch und das war
der Tag wo der schmutzig ist
und niemand hat sich im Keller traut
weil vielleicht der schmutzig dort ist
und meine Tochter
und die warten
7 6 7 so ähnlich wie heute war das
Verhältnis zwischen Mutter und Tochter
nicht immer
ja andere Sachen im Kopf kann ideale ja
als übertrieben meine Tochter gern ins
Ballett geschickt aber weißt du wirklich
umstellen aber ich denke auch ich hatte
dir das essen was sie mir vorstellen
und das war natürlich schon schwierig
aber zum Glück als sie mir richtig das
gemacht was man mit so sagen ja
Schwein so deine eigene Kraft und dein
eigenes
Durchsetzungsvermögen und schaden
nicht respektiert und das hat sie
natürlich auch gespürt und irgendwie ist
das wieso ein Eigentor
als Fußballerin spielte Handy in den
80er und 90er Jahren in der höchsten
Schweizer Liga und fürs
nationalteamreiche und abschlussgewandte
Tatjana Handy die zum 2:0 Einschuss
nach dem Rücktritt startet sie eine
Karriere als Funktionärin ihr Kampf für
den Frauenfußball beginnt nun so richtig
es geht immer wieder
interessiert sie möchte anderen
positionieren
den Frauenfußball in aller Welt
2017 lässt sie der neue Präsident
Jeannine fantino vom einen auf den
anderen Tag fallen so verfärbt er mit
der ganzen alten Garde
einen Namen als hartnäckig gemacht sie
sich als Präsidentin der FCZ Frauen
2019 holt sie der schweizerische
Fußballverband und macht Handy zu
Direktorin Frauenfußball
als erste Frau überhaupt nimmt sie
Einsitz in die Geschäftsleitung des
Fußballverbandes
kurz vor Weihnachten besuche ich Tatjana
Handy an ihrem letzten Arbeitstag für
den schweizerischen Fußballverband in
Muri bei Bern 4 Jahre hat sie die
Frauenabteilung geführt dabei konnte sie
offen und locker sein in der Sache aber
immer fordernd und klar nun müsste sie
aus
sehr
aber nach ein paar Jahren nochmal König
drin
wie zum Beispiel hier gegen Korruption
helfen nur Frauen in Führungspositionen
so
lustigerweise
Organisationen passiert
werden seit Jahrzehnten fordert hat Jana
Handy mehr Professionalität im
Frauenfußball bessere Strukturen und
mehr Frauen in Entscheidungsgremien und
danke kann für mich
Hartnäckigkeit
ja das das ist
sicherlich kritisch dass man weiß dass
das ähm
kämpft worden möchte
nicht immer raus klappt aber der Weg
bist ich habe schon sehr oft
sehr gute Zugang zueinander gefunden ob
schon mir sicher unterschiedliche
Personen sie dass sie hätte sehr
erfordern die Art mein geschaut unbequem
im Jahr
gefordert
einfach Tanja
sagt korrekt und anständig und Mensch
abgeschlossen
Anfang Januar bereit für ein neues Leben
das alte hat in vier Koffern Platz danke
und die zwei drei letzten Nacht vor der
wirklich letztens losgegangen dann ist
geht's
dir gewohntes Umfeld um allein in New
York neu anzufangen ausgerechnet sie die
gesellige mit dem großen Freundeskreis
hallo
danke schön
zwei Wochen später ich treffe Tatjana
Handy an Ihrem neuen Arbeitsort in
Manhattan
Sehenswürdigkeiten
noch gleich in die Büro seiner Baustelle
den der liga-hauptsitz wurde erst
kürzlich von Chicago hierhin verlegt
als sportdirektorin gehört die Berner in
dem Führungsgremium der Liga an ihre
Chefin Liga Jessica Bermann hat Handy
wegen ihrer Fachkompetenz in die USA
geholt gestern sagten sie mir sie sei
ein Superstar Superstar sie ist ein
Superstar definitiv wir sind sehr
glücklich sie bei uns zu haben
als wir die Stelle ausschrieben fragte
ich alle die vom Thema eine Ahnung
hatten wen sollen wir anstellen alle
sagten Tatjana
ich schickte stellen beschriebs sie
sandte ihn mit vielen Änderungen zurück
und ich dachte das ist der Grund warum
alle sagten sie sei qualifiziert weil
sie den Job besser kennt als ich ihn je
entworfen habe
überall wo ich arbeitete UEFA FIFA
Schweizer Verband trieb ich den
Frauenfußball voran gegen alle anderen
deren Fokus bei Männer Fußball lag aber
mit dir und dem Team habe ich das Gefühl
wir machen es alle zusammen es ist nicht
ich gegen Stress sondern wir gemeinsam
als Liga alle gehen in dieselbe Richtung
dieses Gefühl hatte ich noch nie ich
hatte auch nie einen inspirierenden Chef
und ich dachte wow das ist toll
sie verstehen es nicht genau
inspirieren die
Arbeitskolleginnen und Kollegen
und das ist sicher das ohne Männer mit
inspirierend dass sie die die große Lust
hat zu entwickeln mit anderen teilen das
Gefühl
Arbeit beginnt mitten im Schlamassel ein
Missbrauchskandal hat 2021 den
US-amerikanischen Frauenfußball
erschüttert
die Untersuchung zeigt systematischer
Missbrauch und sexuelles Fehlverhalten
waren an der Tagesordnung
erste Konsequenzen sind lebenslange
sperren für vier Trainer und strenge
Auflagen für weitere Betreuer und Clubs
und ich finde so traurig und so schlimm
ist ist das Land jetzt hier die Liga die
erste weltweit
sondern das in Zukunft so wie möglich zu
finden
Feierabend von Manhattan aus macht sich
Tatjana Handy auf den Heimweg
sie wohnt in Jersey City auf der anderen
Seite des Hudson River täglich kommt sie
an der nine eleven Gedenkstätte vorbei
wo einst die Twin Towers standen
nach einer knappen Stunde zu Hause
alleine
oder viel leichter sie beginnt ein neues
Leben beruflich wie privat
irgendwelche Sachen gemacht
mache um mit Ziel ist eigentlich dass
ich hier
ruhig gewesen und dann sind wir doch
immer zu mir kommen
die Laute ganz leise ich habe den
Eindruck die sonst total viel lernen
sich selbst gerade neu kennen
es ist Ende Februar 2023 ich erhalte von
Tatjana Handy eine rätselhafte Video
Nachricht
offenbar ist sie für einen Kurzbesuch
schon wieder zurück in Zürich viel
früher als ursprünglich geplant
bei New York
Handy ist kurzfristig zurück in Zürich
nicht wegen Heimweh behauptet sie
sondern wegen Terminen sie nutzt die
Gelegenheit trifft Eltern Freundinnen
und spontan auch ihren alten Förderer
18 Jahre lang arbeitete FIFA Präsident
Platte er war ihr Mentor und vermindert
sind sie des Lobes füreinander voll
verwandt wird
ganz viel Macht oder zu viel
also gerade beim Umfallen mit dem
exekutiv kommen mit direkt
Notizen gemacht und ich weiß es noch
genau ist im Großen
und anderen Seite ja das machen wir
selber
mir wird gleich klar
übersetze nie ein schlechtes Wort
verlieren irritieren für mich haben denn
die Schlagzeilen und Skandale nichts mit
ihr gemacht und wie sieht sie ihre
eigene fifa-zeit rückblickend ich muss
Nachfragen
mehr als Mensch
nicht sagen
Anfang April zurück in New York nach
drei Monaten wird allmählich alles
Alltag für Tatjana Handy auch im Job
kommt sie mehr und mehr an
in Los Angeles das ist mit der großen
Text tschüss
Frauenfußball hat einen riesigen
Stellenwert in der Welt in der Henni nun
tätig ist und es sind Frauen die hier
Millionen in den Frauensport investieren
etwa Hollywoodstar Natalie Portman und
Tennislegende Billie Jean King in Los
Angeles wer mit einem Club in die Liga
einsteigen will benötigt 100 Millionen
Dollar die Investitionen zahlen sich aus
die Liga
Magneten rapino die auffälligste
Fußballerin Boot Gabriel Trump die
Sterne
auf die zweimalige Weltmeisterin Lloyd
ihr Geld steckt im Clubhaus New York
ich möchte dem Sport etwas zurückgeben
für mich war es schon immer die beste
Liga der Welt es braucht auch künftig
Zeit und Geld wir müssen uns stetig
verbessern
im neuen Leben nur auf sich gestellt
hallo hallo alles gut
im Hintergrund Mama
tschüss
Tschüss bis bald
und dann gibt's frohe Kunde aus der
Schweiz
17 Jahre nach der
Fußball-Europameisterschaft der Männer
und 2008 findet 2025 wieder ein großes
Fußballturnier in der Schweiz statt 25
schweren Herzens musste sie dieses
Projekt loslassen nicht nur das tut
manchmal noch weh auch das Alleinsein
macht ihre New York zu schaffen
gesagt
Schweiz
oder so und hier haben jetzt
gefühlt Ruhe
so nachdenklich habe ich Tatjana Handy
noch nie erlebt in der Schweiz genoss
sie die Geselligkeit in vollen Zügen
hier kommt sie endlich sich selbst nahe
so scheint mir
und das machen natürlich
schwierig und und toll sie also
einerseits private Situation Training
von mir eine Frau plus gleichzeitig das
Angebot hier heirats
also ich glaube es ist wirklich crazy
paar Wochen sie und
da habe ich schon lange nicht gewusst
was machst du jetzt
was Mini private Situation und Training
habe glaube ich wirklich dass das eine
hilfreich ist das ist wo das glaube ich
leider wahrscheinlich Trainingsprozess
e komplett neu anfangen
Jahre hätte das gedacht
Handy ist angekommen in New York
angekommen im neuen Leben